hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to doom eternal we've
got the biggest what do they call this
thing I don't want to call it a butthole
because I don't want to call absolutely
everything in this game a butthole but
what else could I call it oh yeah oh
that's that can't that can't oh where am
I now where did I go wait a minute what
the hell oh I went underneath okay maybe
because that would have been difficult
to find but thank you I don't know if
that's how technology is supposed to
work jamming a teeth into a goop hole no
no that's better than butthole yeah what
are we looking for there's a 1-up oh
[Music]
okay
god you guys just turned into the most
evil bastards ever I thought it was
supposed to be something like subtle
influence this is just like we're evil
we're evil we're really really evil were
evil and they're all just conga line
dancing down or so so even we're evil
laugh now or gone gone oh it's an
invisible pit who is behind me hey hey
hey [ __ ] [ __ ] boink gone no more
you literally don't exist
goodbye trip point to from what's that a
twofer oh it wasn't oh hi how you doing
there wait for you oh yes please God I
really should use blood punch shouldn't
I I really should I'm gonna go max armor
I'm gonna do for the blood punch thing
because I've been saying it forever that
I need to do it all so this is the first
time I've had an energy drink in a long
long time I just was feeling really
sluggish I don't know if this is gonna
amp up my gaming or my aim is just gonna
shake to death so we're gonna find out I
ordinarily don't do caffeine so this is
gonna be a trip Oh what did I miss
where am I how did I get down here I
missed some stuff I'm gonna have to go
back a la in this level because I want
to get everything because I'm starting
to learn that I need the upgrades to be
able to survive I'm just doing a far for
this
will it well that's awfully inconvenient
fruit with that thing for setting up in
this place but not my problem
boom hey whoa whoa whoa bud get out of
here whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa what
is that beautiful device I've never
wanted anything so badly in my entire
existence I want it so badly oh my god
super Gore nest following reports of UAC
cultist presence at the Loch reactor
Recon teams in Phil gamma and in Phil
Hector attempted to gain entry to the
lock and assess the situation
the final transmission indicated a
massive demonic presence entering the
reactor facility through continuum gates
an emergency Global council meeting
approved medical arc responds to the
situation at the lock reactor the
assembled coalition strike forces
included for us battle mech divisions -
Connie you are long-range naval
artillery barrage fleet 27 us Nightbird
Apaches three NATO shock troop
battalions to Konya Rapid Response levee
tank divisions and 18,000 coalition
Special Forces units that's a lot of
people you tell me that all those people
went in here and weren't able to do it
the initial bombardment from the LR nab
was met with immediate response from
invasion forces 8,000 units attacked
gargoyles 8,000 that's it that's thing
that sank your 32 vessels oh it's just
8,000 come on guys okay so long story
short it didn't go according to plan
ground zero of the invading force and
less accademia deeds get destroyed this
now and sees no way to stem why didn't
you nuke it Oh to recommend the response
total nuclear annihilation
yeah that why haven't you done that yet
that would be like the first thing you
would do to screw it all if that's the
place shut it down that energy drink is
gonna be a mistake I can tell ooh wait a
minute I may have missed something
oh it's not open yet ah damn it okay
I'll get it a bit whoa
can't block me from this okay apparently
you can whoa is that blood punch did I
actually remember to do it for once Wow
you just kind of suck
oh really that one takes that one's a
big big boom really that one takes three
that's annoying
there's a radiation suit over there okay
so why do I need this radiation suit I'm
actually guessing that I don't need it
right now
there's something in there who is also
something purple there all right I'm
gonna get this yes I know what a rad
suit does I played the first one all
right what that do all right thank you
how do you get there how do you get down
there okay interesting interesting
I don't know how long this radiation
suit lass ho there we go okay got that
open nothing else
secretive up there I'm Josh guessing
okay I'm gonna move forward that's a
good argument that's real good that's
very convincing I'm not gonna listen to
you oh ho ho ho just barely
I don't think I still have a suit do I
oh hi
come on shoot shoot now sit down the
Sheep
okay did I get it who is alive oh my god
those people wait who am I supposed to
kill you you guys you part of the kill
squad I'm not gonna win this wait who's
part of it
how many people are part of it that's
what I don't understand I guess I gotta
jump down okay there's something I've
got don't do glory kills I forgot about
that
there I go doing another glory kill
[Music]
there we go okay now I'm getting hurt by
the radiation oh there we go okay that
went well yes I got that
and I guess technically I'm still fine
on the radiation front okay there's a
way around and then way back around okay
I think my radiation suit just died his
weight down to okay so there's something
down here
yeah oh that's a cute boy that's pretty
good okay it keeps popping me back up
here and now that I have no radiation
suit there's gonna be a bit more of a
challenge
oh god this is a dead end
well then why did I come here how do I
get out of here oh oh oh I didn't see
this oh well to the herd chamber thanks
don't mind me sitting in the poison goo
it's fine actually good stay Steven not
get hurt
oh we did oh never mind I guess he's
just gonna give it to me
oh no it was a trap can I see I can't
see I can't see okay nice flip dude who
needs the machine-gun anymore who needs
the machine-gun ever no one no one ever
needs it this is all you had ever need
oh that is the good stuff
oh yeah Louise piddly guns you would
have those oh it is that my that's the
same as the one I have right here well
if if every soldier on this planet has
that gun they should have no excuse this
thing is a is a freaking bolt rifle from
40 K which I'm gonna compare everything
in this game too apparently
rightio it I did that nothing else in
this game in this level this reminds me
of the BFG division
dormant state to nearby control
terminals will need to be manually
activated to restore well that seems
rather arbitrary and only slightly
[ __ ] but whatever getting to the
other guns that going up to seven and
eight is gonna be difficult
oh well is this all I have to do to I
really just have to throw this switch
when having to be kicking [ __ ] out of
all this technology oh oh oh oh oh poor
baby oh no your big stupid heart need to
find an alternate routing just die you
[ __ ]
whoa oh you duck right at the last
second that's not fair how tough is this
thing not tough enough is the answer
alright give me this Oh new friends no
I'm actually low on ammo what is that
that was not worth it was not worth it
at all
I need you to give me your things
there we go that's a little sloppy
definitely didn't keep my armor up on
that fight but what can you do all right
what did I miss out on nothing yeah give
me do upgrade what was this a secret
really
this is a secret mobile turret ooh oh my
god Oh a shield oh this is what Hugo was
yelling at me to do the whole time is
like use your shield that I'm like
shield who any shield in yeah whatever
yeah shield that that sounds great I'm a
frickin shield of course why would I not
do that hey Vega can you keep these
things coming because I really
appreciate it oh that's why would you
not do that why would you never do that
that's so useful oh how long is it last
damn that lasts a long time I don't know
if he'll absorbs damage the entire time
it's open but that is really convenient
that is supremely convenient there's
something else over here and I've missed
oh it was locked
duh it was a reason why I couldn't go
over there oh my oh oh Sarah there's a
turret there there's a totem somewhere
okay you this give me that
where is I got a play where's the totem
[ __ ] is that like a oh that looks like a
pit of death where's the totem I don't
see the totem I'm oh there it is oh so I
do have to keep going this way
give me something to shoot give me
something to hook OOP that would be
instant death oh my God look at that
Sarlacc pit oh office and there's the
totem I got a mail it I think yep I sure
do
[ __ ] where'd you go you [ __ ] all
right you lose oh I'm so mobile I feel
so good about myself and everything I've
been doing where am I going where am I
going
I made it over here apparently I didn't
know if I was supposed to go here wait a
minute oh there's something up there oh
wait no no no I see it I see it there's
a window out there that I can get up
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
nice alright and then whoa hey bud looks
like you're one of the dudes that lost
the fight unfortunate for you hey thanks
thanks pal
dude this Red Bull is making my stomach
go insane oh I've got so many curdles in
my girdles is there something up here
that I can get to hello who is this a
secret yeah it's looks secretive this
looks fun wall was here was there a
point to this can I step on this I
definitely see something up there yep
yep yes yes I even hi wahoo you I see go
go go yes yes yes I love it except I
don't was I supposed to just jump up
here oh my god I was I'm supposed to be
able to just jump up there then what was
the point of all that fun maneuvering oh
there's a wall oh there was a wall climb
out damn oh I'm so dumb oh my goodness
at least I'm gonna be able to get this
running start
hope yep yep yep nice oh look at that
main theme Doom 3 main theme hell yeah
hell yeah thank you
what do we have here oh don't mind if I
ruin yeah
the long-range glory kill that's just
like convenience how are you not dead
hey how many do you mean are you Fanning
yourself
yeah don't flatter yourself Wow
I got posin sorry bud all right whew
yeah anything down there oh I do have a
radiation meter interesting I didn't
even notice that before oh yeah I'll
stand up standing the radiation goop
understanding the fecal River here on my
knee ooh I want that now how do you get
that how do get it how do I do
hmm Oh over here god I'm so stupid
hello okay so we've got kind of wall to
climb there huh okay is there anything
up here that I need to know about her am
I really just going for this I think I'm
just going for this oh hey there you are
how are you doing good to see you you
one of my friends that died a long time
ago yeah don't worry still killing the
demons you know how it do oh it's a
thankless job that never stops
she's is de Visser ated
all right pretty good pretty good
all in this I forgot about the speed
boost after a glory kill like that all
right got the keys so now all I need to
do is get back to the place open up
these bad boys jump over these if
there's anything special that I missed
one last combat zone and then Bob's my
uncle
I'm stop it I don't want it I don't want
it I don't want it oh god I'm a little
too close to you okay out of here was
there anything in there lalala I missed
a secret back there you're not gonna
give me this oh no back there no yeah
I'm good
okay ow god damn it listen you're an
[ __ ]
[Applause]
now there's a new one
alright so there's something over here
something oh oh
wondering about my loved ones rights
that's what I'm doing oh I'm all the way
back here which means that I can go here
it's all coming together baby it's all
coming together where am I going oh I
didn't know where I was going with that
one
I'm confused cuz I don't remember why
there was secrets here
oh they're interesting all right
hmm okay now why did I come here this is
the question of the day don't think that
you can dead all right where am I oh I'm
here oh my goodness I'm stuck on a rock
yeah I don't know where the Slayer room
is but I got the Slayer key so where is
the there she blows all right I still
need to get that and I still need to get
that so I just got to figure out how to
open those and I'm good but let me just
go ahead and go to the Slayer gate
hey fast-travel unlocked finally all
right and I get to go through the tunnel
of doom literally the tunnel of doom I
got a funny feeling there's gonna be
like totems in this to power people up
there's gonna be extra surprises it's
gonna be all kinds of nutty in here but
I'm gonna go in with my Gatling gun
first and foremost
yeah I need okay let me get you whoa god
oh my god what oh god I really screwed
up literally every part of that yep okay
dude I do not need that for you guys
cool that's how you get a whole mess of
stuff oh stop it stop it you sassy sue
bull where am I
multiple hell nights one a piece of this
well you can have it sir whoa get out of
my way what he'll get out of my way whoa
I hate laughs look all right cool good
that's how we're gonna do this okay let
me get the big guns out once piece wants
peace
wants peace who wants peace come on you
get a piece not that that was necessary
boy [ __ ] you're dead you are gonna get a
whole lot of this and then you are gonna
get a whole lot of this
done easy fun good smooth smooth like
baby bottom smooth like bottom of a baby
getting really good okay so what have I
missed in the grand scheme of things not
too much let's go back to mix some
square so there's something some at the
beginning of this some mole oh here we
go how did I miss that
he'll girth part one he'll growth cancer
like gross reproduction rates outpatient
they've freaking it an exorbitant level
okay dude do demons do demons have sex
do they so the thing they need to worry
about I don't even know
ah that war not quite here we go tada
finally made it there oh hey welcome to
the party BAM hi how you doing anyway
goodbye thank you thank you I'll see you
around thanks for standing here for
probably a million years all right what
about the lower area energy station oh I
still haven't done a ton of stuff there
I think I've gotten most of the
collectibles though alright I think I go
to the energy station and that's when I
get what I need to go here did I
activate the other side of the energy
station did I do that I did not do that
did I just go on a complete side path oh
here God a barrette so stupid I am dumb
is the answer to that question I'm just
very dumb right I'm supposed to put the
keys and the whole reason I got the keys
of course of course yes the keys right
the keys in the goop the goop whole
point in your goop whole point
thank you oh yeah now you're forced to
open your mouth
airshaft do you mean lungs is this the
things lungs is that why it's a mouth
because it's breathing here because
that's how hell works loves to breathe
alright cool I'm going in the hell hole
oh it is an air shaft well I see nothing
here another hole dude I love falling
hole hi oh it's the thing there you go
alright there you have it oh no oh oh oh
oh no oh no oh you're about to get a
little shock treatment yeah let's do
that
yeah you know what I'm all for that but
those great that sounds really great
there you go there you go
oh no oh oh
all mm-hmm
where hello here how hey stop it am I
actually supposed to be running here
okay I bet there's gonna be secrets on
the way no actually I grabbed all the
secrets didn't I ow okay oh really
you're gonna have buttholes the whole
way through aren't you you sack of crap
uh-huh I would have thought the music
would be a little more amped up for this
all right
easy-peasy whoa you know what actually
goodbye you know how that yeah i'll rip
and tear nice dead huh oh i have a timer
maybe I should have been paying
attention that I guess they would have
all blown up anyway all right any
secrets secrets see I didn't even
explore that area that's fine
[Music]
oh there we go apparently I'm out oh
damn you had a bad day god I hope that
was connected to your balls
God is there just a big sack like a huge
set of demon balls just floating out
there oh hell yeah oh hell yeah
Oh completion that's why they call me
the completion er always every time yes
yes yes killing it killing it why did I
say that I wasn't gonna go for
collections it is fun to go for
collections in this game it really is I
don't know why I thought that I wouldn't
this is actually fun I'm super about
this I'm actually gonna have to go back
to the old levels and get all this stuff
that I didn't get just because I see can
I even go back to the old levels is that
even a thing that I can do probably not
you know wasn't even considering it Hara
was just flying on by not taking life
you know while I was here dr. Samuel
Hayden dr. Aden that dr. Hayden the dr.
Hayden that put me away in purgatory and
then to the last game that I somehow
mysteriously escaped from and I don't
remember quite how that happened that
dr. Hayden where's he been this whole
time where's he been hiding out where's
he been where has he been
in an unbelievable turn of events the
super gore nest has been destroyed
reports from arc personnel in the field
say that they have seen a significant
decrease in demonic activity across the
globe many believe this is proof that
the dooms lair himself has in fact
joined a resistance effort and has
successfully eliminated key figures
within the ranks of the challenged
operatives working inside the UAC
contest organization claim that the
leader of that division priest daya
Cranach was in fact removed from his
office recently by the salir himself as
key leadership within the mortally
challenged continued to fall we are
seeing a decreased threat from the
demons on all fronts this has given the
resistance
advantage the UAC continues to deny any
knowledge of his existence as surviving
members of the arc Network it is the
belief of this station that these
reports are in fact true we believe the
Slayer has joined us in the battle
against the demons nice anyone still
listening to this broadcast know that
there is hope and he is out there I mean
whatever must have happened I must have
just gotten out of whatever purgatory I
was in trapped by Samuel Hayden gotten
this facility and then started kicking
ass because it was like as soon as I was
on the scene a priest was dead I got in
there whop BAP gone and now already a
second priest is dead within a day so
I'm beginning to suspect oh I can
mission select [ __ ] I only missed one
point there and one toy there I get 60
I've been nailing most of it actually
I've been actually getting it but I
won't go back right now
but I will go spend some of my do daddy
points I think that's the technical term
for them they are do daddy points I will
get you soon I will get you soon on
maker boy I will get you soon I think
I'm gonna go for the weapon mods oh yeah
come here
there you go why did you hide these away
from me come on don't be so silly all
right um I guess I could switch this
over to micro missiles to be perfectly
honest I think I actually might be
better now that I have like the chain
gun and then the the are bolused for the
big old real gun I should start using
that as the sniper more yeah
now that's a bolt gun there's a lot of
demonic symbolism hmm unless that's a
holy symbol
maybe it is I'm gonna save two of my
doo-dads so that I can have Sentinel
batteries on hand just in case there's
any particular reason that I would need
them okay without further ado let's go
to wherever the hell we're going in now
arc complex or the AR C having destroyed
the super Gordon s the hunt for the
remaining help priest continues unable
to identify his position due to the con
makers interference you travel to the AR
C complex headquarters of the armored
resist Coalition in search of duck your
Samuel Haydon leader of the human
resistance on earth and the only person
capable of finding the heinel priest
interesting so he's now the leader of
the resistance because he used to be you
AC got a bone with a Sammy boy what did
you do about
that's probably not good doesn't bode
well for me fine oh-kay down I go ow
[Music]
point
love it I'm getting so in the zone with
this kind of stuff that I just I kind of
like tune it out because I'm just
enjoying myself so if I stop screaming
like an idiot during these moments
just remember it's uh having fun except
for you you [ __ ] boom bullet punch I
always forget about you it's it because
the normal melee is such a wimpy baby
did I fly the secret how did is it I
didn't know that was a thing where did
that one come from
wah bah bah bah bah wah ah you want to
play don't you
I marry you
what
come here where are you ah too late for
you
easy peasy give me a challenge hey but
hey look a challenge
did I say challenge I meant absolutely
no problem whatsoever
come on give me something to blood punch
the pawing my butt ow
and that that was unfortunate her yet
[Music]
music is getting good news is getting
good
Oh
things are getting spicy oh my
ow you stop that nonsense
whoa this one's just a lot of fighting
and I like it
damn it miss that ooh I like it a lot I
like it a lot I like it a lot
enlightening you sing I'll see about
that
hello hi could you hoarding all these
supplies for me thanks bud
thanks big bud this one
whoa what do we got there oh this looks
like a big payload kind of day
yeah there's nothing left after that I
think this is the kind of level where
they're like all right so you've learned
a lot of the tricks you know a lot of
the basic recipes let's just throw a
whole bunch of stuff at ya and smooth
down I go see how you fare nice
huh interesting just gonna give up like
that huh just gonna fall over and die
are you oh oh what am i oh I'm in sludge
that's why I can't move
good I'm gonna yeah
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] whoa hey
ow okay that's no good all right
interesting interesting oh that went
well
and by well I mean I goofed it who
dropped all this goop on the ground
sure is detrimental for my abilities
here oh you didn't do so good so am I
too late in the whole rescue and Samuel
Hayden thing or is he just a [ __ ] baby
anyway and he just flopped over and died
that's the question that I'm asking I'm
beginning to say that he is not a [ __ ]
baby because his robot body seemed to be
pretty tough so if he went down
something bad happened okay sounds good
how do I do that
Oh ever boink
oh why did I do that
whoa it's a cyber mag Lluis okay so I
need I need blood punch for you that's
right but for now I don't have blood
punch ready so I'm just gonna go with
the plain old regular punch
there we go sorry but didn't have a
blood punch for you so you just had to
eat your own guts which is fine you
probably don't mind that I love it
whoa
ah
damnit that looks bad and that was what
matters looking good in this game God
look at the bar the progress bar I've
killed so many demons and I've only
gotten one in 2/3 of a bar done this
level is gonna be immense die kill me
there we go and there's gotta be a
there's so many secrets in there all
right I passed one there but that looks
like I need to get to that zone first so
hello I don't know what that was that
exploded behind me but I'm not gonna
worry about it
remote detonate I don't really need it
but I guess I can get it but I don't
need it but if I have to I'll get it
oh speaking of I haven't unlocked my
points I haven't used any of my weapon
blah who do you think you are friend a
friend a friend friend don't just don't
even bother okay okay that seems good
runes
I've got aura suit I got ten suit points
sure health sure cooldown sure sure why
not give it to me cool all right there's
more secrets here stuff up that's why I
gotta be able to get up somehow looks
like there's something above
huh okay so there is supposed to be some
kind of uh whoa there's a staircase
oh well that seems pretty obvious now
that you just pointed out to me I
thought that was gonna be some
roundabout way I'm so used to butthole
land but didn't know that it was this
gonna be there Oh
cue ball why do you even exist what
demon made you who bang doin demon land
to make one of you because you are not
intelligently designed the
one-night-stand gone wrong and demon
University what is this January 24th
2163 there is no chance we have blood
samples pulled from the Mars base event
that show his blood type is a B+ he is
male with a genome that makes him very
much a member of the human race but the
enhanced strength speed and athleticism
would indicate otherwise but we can see
from the blood samples that there are
foreign bodies present of unknown origin
I cannot as a contributing member of the
scientific community agree with the
assumption by some of my colleagues that
he is for lack of a better word a God an
avenging angel the right hand of doom
here to save humanity from its sins but
I cannot ignore that the timing of his
arrival the identity of his enemies the
fire and brimstone element to this
catastrophe me currently find ourselves
in as it has definitely shaken my
scientific resolve yeah okay well I'm no
God but man I am handsome so you got to
look out for that one I am just a
wrecking ball of pure testosterone
bowling my way in here and you cannot
stop me ah let's do the mobile turret I
don't know what good it'll do
maybe if I just need to get some major
fire power down on something look at
that oh my god oh my god okay yeah
that's overkill where am I going
nito there's something underneath mate
Oh
Epping master idk FA was that like the
ammo one I think not her century it was
I think that was ammo and keys can't
remember I used to have all those super
memorized was I supposed to do that I
don't know felt like the right thing to
do
okay so there hi
[Music]
well didn't mean a blood punch but
apparently I did you know III blood
punch time now immediately gonna get a
Cyberman campus how do I get there
wait let's go back this back turn
there's is a key there that somehow I
missed how did I miss that I'll punch a
slayer gate I got that oh there you are
okay oh nothing
noise noise alright let's do this I'm
ready for a slayer game let's do this
easy peasy easy peace me kachunk thank
you
i've thought of me year
all right what do we got oh my goodness
is that a cyberdemon are you kidding me
that's a sigh Bodie mo oh my god oh my
God where am I hopefully [ __ ] what the
hell happened I could not see a goddamn
thing oh my god is a cyber demo holy
[ __ ] the big boy is big boy ours here oh
my god what are you doing down there get
out here eat that please eat your
medicine oh it's too savvy demos oh my
god I need some fodder please oh yeah oh
yeah oh yeah Oh big boy goes down hard
blood Bunch please boo
you are a soul pure big these guys are
no joke
let's get my yes baby yes Babu oh I was
so close to getting you with that God
you are just a face full of evil okay I
need to oh no he's dead
never mind whoop oh you oh gods you're a
boss batshit [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] give me you
give me give me give me
you freeze you get shot come on shot
shot oh god I got I got hit
damn it okay
all right you want dance book
Oh
that was fun that was fun that was a fun
one I was fun that was plain old fun no
joke that was just fun I love that Oh
some good [ __ ] everybody Oh some good
[ __ ] my friends I did die I will admit I
did die and that is unfortunate I did
die however that's what the 1ups are for
and that's why I collected them but that
was fun Oh No god damn it
all right Samuel baby let's see if I can
save you from whatever hell you're in
BAM now you don't want to come down here
my dude I don't know why you felt the
need to jump into your own death but hey
save me the trouble
all right blood punch it is then or
anything in here yes how can I have it
there's something down there
hmm let me in let me then over here
here yes easy easy easy easy lor the ark
enter global mill available our armored
response coalition is designed with the
sole purpose contacting blablabla Haydn
overseeing all aspects of the air sea
weapon tech development said about
repurposing the USC facility as many
votes were unaffected by the invasion
due to the remote location side levels
Oh automated security operate by
powerful Aird design for weapon to
zelban and mass production meaning they
could be repurposed overnight well
that's obviously convenient that's
auspiciously convenient efficiency
redefined innovation for a new age io
logisitics manufacture oh hi yes give me
please this is for the health for blood
I like it seems like I'm gonna be
getting a lot more blood punches Jam
[Applause]
Samantha Sam Sam Sammy Bob Amy where the
hell am i jumping to what where the hell
am i jumping to oh here we go
bunk what are you doing in there what
are you crazy kids doing in there what
are you nuts Oh kids doing BAM
whoa no not that what yep that one
yes did I do it okay
talking about me 0:05 subject analysis
of Doom's lair February 2nd 2163 maybe
he is a god hey maybe he represents
humankind's range their will to
persevere to overcome that which would
threaten our survival and he is
uncompromising a relentless beam of
violence that knows no mention of the
hesitation shown by our many leaders and
politicians during our time of judgment
can he overcome them alone if he can't
we as a species all species will not
survive okay yes sir no pressure these
gods laying it on thick there doctor
whatever your name was I can't really
remember that's a bit of a stretch
unless this works out like [ __ ] back no
that's not right little weird hope damn
it god damn god damn damn it Tim damn a
dimmadome Doug's Dale dimmadome
what-what-what-what I knew it I have to
do I'm just getting there go
nope I don't know what I have to do
apparently oh I see there's another wall
over there
right it's gotta play the world's
biggest game of hopscotch
whoop whoop what Bob got it but there's
also window there that's definitely not
something I could break but there's the
hint of green in there that just makes
me want to go for it ah nope didn't work
at all apparently yum point boink
okay I made it here hi goodbye done
well I'm full on armor so I can't
exactly take advantage of all the
delicious deliciousness that you're
giving to me who is this lady who are
you you just may I you just a robo
listen you're getting on my nerves
well you've toned it down there I came
out the womb Sinan arrived in the sense
of ejaculation what he targeted God I
don't like you there's something down
there I want it oh yes why did I come
down here I dunno but I Here I am
is this where I was supposed to go oh I
thought this was like a secret path hi
goodbye
I am sir secret feel like this this
feels like the place for a secret but
apparently not all right
damn they died so good
Oh
of so many demos I love it
[Applause]
BAM
you born to die my friend
oh that that was spicy that was a spicy
move my friend
not bad please give me a challenge I'm
starting to snooze here oh wow you're
lucky you're lucky I was out of RAM row
you're lucky my dude you're lucky very
very lucky Oh what do we have here
Samuel Hayden all right sit oh that
looks fun that looks fun in 21:50
following the loss of communication
between the Earth and Mars based
facilities UAC director dr. Samuel
Hayden suddenly resurfaced on earth
before the a.n council the demonic
invasion of Earth had already begun and
dr. Hayden had arrived just in time to
provide aid he supplied the resistance
armies with argent technology and
advanced armaments taking helm on the
newly formed a RC as lead director dr.
Aidan's tactical and scientific acumen
were invaluable to the war effort and as
soon as given full command over there
all resistance efforts by the global
council the AARC engaged the demons with
bleeding-edge tech exosuits and heavy
frame battle mechs but found themselves
fighting a losing battle operation hull
breaker was Samuels final plan a
powerful counter-attack that ultimately
ended in failure his robotic torso
retrieved by a RC soldier Samuel has now
tended to and monitor by skeleton crew
of scientists they have been given
contingency orders to safeguard his body
along with the crucible obtained on Mars
you know Sammy boy this wouldn't have
been such a problem if you had to put me
away in stasis he better have some
answers you better have some good
answers ain't gonna tolerate no nonsense
answers oh oh hey wait wait wait hang on
a second
not how this is supposed to go oh my god
I'm losing incredibly
geez okay I failed even though I just
killed him damn it all right I wasn't
ready for the big boy I didn't have my
big gun capable of taking big boys out
out all right big boy
oh he's dead oh he's so dead already
I'm gonna go straight from you to you Oh
God that better have not knocked off my
time get over here done easy you know if
I actually use my big guns that do a lot
of big boy damage I actually do a lot of
big boy damage as it turns out that's
just firing BFG lasers please tell me
those are just blasting BFG blasts into
the sky that's awesome all right where
am I headed is will hi bye
bye-bye bye-bye bye-bye
how about bye-bye what else that one
much that last fight went much worse
than I had anticipated
hi oh I have no ammo there oh this is
embarrassing
oh this oh this is oh god that's
that's really embarrassing that bow is
really embarrassing
Oh goodbye goodbye oh wow I must have
missed something back there I did oh hey
in here hi Oh laughs whoopee laughs she
who would lash I hate you I hate you
whiplash you're really annoying but a
good fighter I guess and that's what
matters right
hello and whatever not gonna use it
anyway
Tachi yeah what is this thing that's
zapping me with energy like this not him
you silly Billie's okay sure whatever
you say freak okay down ya down oh
that's funny okay wait now that was a
funny joke that was pretty funny okay I
like that
oh come on that was like a super Death
Punch
[Music]
how many more bullets see you need you
plasma hogs
in spicy spicy Oh getting so spicy
forgive me you thank you woof what can I
get this over there oh my goodness
holy crap Ola it's getting dicey
holy crap where am I I don't want none
of this whoa hey buddy hey are you doing
Wow no wrong attachment wrong attachment
nailed it nailed it baby nailed it
okay got you gonna get you it's gonna
get you five wrong guy to go would never
mind he's dead
perfect guy to go up against
by
come on blood punch that's the only
thing that the mechanics like it's never
really solidified for me cuz I mean I
get the concept of a y-you so my god
man those whiplashes they are tough
stuff well yeah the way bam guns oh this
feels so good to be at this level that's
just like this aggressive just breakneck
pace of everything everything is coming
at yet a million oh this feels good this
is what they were building towards and I
know it now oh I'm so close
well you need a blood but I do not have
a blood punch ready oh my god they
wanted me to get this a lot sooner than
I had it you come here [ __ ] all dead so
debri things dead come in she pictures
Christmas oh my god the rage is real the
rage is so real oh my god with my bare
hands
who's alive who's left nobody jiminy
Christmas
good god that was pure destruction the
entire time okay okay who the arc part -
the arc begin running operations from
the mobile commands carriers he born
command character designed for
long-range strategy operations which
would serve as arc HQ their primary
objective to locate the source of the
hell growth infestation and in doing so
shutting down the emergence of hell
portals and closing the gate between
dimensions at the heart of the armored
court Response Coalition is an
aggressive
research and development program in
pursuit of new military technologies as
part of dr. Hayden's commitment UAC
resources under his direction including
some of the most powerful AI ever
created have been deployed in service of
weapon developments designed to face the
health threat ahead on all right
interesting however unfortunately I'm
out of time for this episode it looks
like we're gonna confront Samuel Hayden
get to the bottom of the mystery of
where I was who I am and I'm human so I
think that's what they're doing because
before it was saying that the doom
Slayer was some alien species person but
now it's like I'm verifiably human so it
must be tying this doom guy into the
doom guy from the original games somehow
and I bet it's gonna be kind of
contrived but I think I'm gonna like it
I don't know if I like it as much as an
internal badass that's on a quest for
vengeance for being betrayed and making
a mistake a big deal with the devil
however the game's fun and at the end of
the day it's a game so thank you
everybody so much for watching check out
more doom that I played in the
description below and other games that I
played across my channel subscribe for
more and ring the bell if you want to
know exactly when the next video is
gonna come out leave a like if you
enjoyed the video and you're enjoying
the series so far because I am thanks
again and as always I will see you in
the next video bye bye
[Music]